number seven on the list we have the
Danish Gambit one of the more common
openings that you'll see Pawnee or
Pawnee five and white just starts giving
up material as fast as possible starting
with Pawn to D4 after it takes the pawn
is just going to come up here to C3
allowing his opponent to continue to
take that material look at his opponent
doesn't have to but the intent would be
for these opponents to take Bishop here
to C4 not even warring if black takes
more material if black does continue to
take Bishop here to B2 all of a sudden
white is down two Pawns in material but
as you can see he has a very aggressive
set at both of his Bishops are both
eyeing down on this King side black has
none of his pieces involved into the
game white has a fairly open Lane for
his Queen to get involved both sides of
the board in the middle very easily can
get his Knights very easily involved
Castle Queen side or King side depending
on if you need some safety or if he
wants to be very aggressive